[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome back.
In this video, we want to share
the approach to an API product
mindset and give you examples
on how to design your first API
product.
Let's get started.
I often get this question
from my customers
at the start of an engagement.
What is an API?
The formal definition of API
is defined as application
programming interface.
It is a way for systems to
communicate with each other.
It leverages and reuses data,
functions, and applications,
and combines them into new
business opportunities.
And furthermore, it
connects consumers
of data, systems,
and applications
with providers of the same.
Now that you have the
formal definition,
you are probably
asking yourself,
how does this
affect my business?
In the next few slides, we will
discuss a recommended approach
to designing your APIs, making
it easier for the developer
to discover and
begin using your APIs
in order to implement their
application with speed.
So now, you may ask,
what is an API product
and why is it important
to my business?
Approaching an API with the
consumer experience in mind
is the cornerstone
of an API product.
We call this an API-first
approach or outside
in thinking.
Let me give you an example.
For those of you who
are MBA fans, when
you think of Steph
Curry's basketball shoes,
you might envision a
cool blue and white shoe
that enables you to jump
higher and farther than anyone
else on the court.
You might envision yourself
shooting 3-point baskets
from midcourt.
Now, the shoe doesn't
really do that,
But it creates the vision of
someone doing awesome things
when they wear that shoe.
You want to build
the same vision
or need with an API product.
With a focus on the
consumer experience,
the API product can encompass
a similar vision and experience
for an API.
Let's dig into how this is done.
To understand the need
for an API product,
you must first
understand the user.
Let's start with asking
four key questions
centered around the
user of your API.
Who is the user?
What are the user's needs?
Why do they need it?
When do they need it?
The answer to the first
question is simple.
The user of your API is
an application developer
who will create
applications using your API.
The application developer is
also known as the API consumer.
Let me give you an example.
A lottery company
in the UK wanted
to make purchasing a lottery
ticket easy for their players.
Their goal was to give
everyone the ability
to make a purchase
anytime, anywhere.
However, there were
some regulations
that needed to be met
before the player could
purchase the ticket.
First, the purchase
of a lottery ticket
must be made from within the UK.
This requires that
the application be
able to geolocate the player.
Luckily, most telcos have a
location API available for use.
Next, the lottery
requires the purchaser
to be at least 16 years of
age, therefore the application
must be able to
identify the player
and look up the player's profile
to determine if the minimum age
qualifications are met.
This can be done
through an identity API.
Once the minimum
qualifications have been met
and the player is
ready to purchase,
the application must
provide the ability to pay.
The billing API
allows the application
to accept payment and
the player to complete
the purchase of lottery ticket.
The API product is formed
as a collection of APIs
that provides the user with
the experience of purchasing
a lottery ticket and ensuring
that the minimum qualifications
are met.
Purchase must be
made within the UK,
purchaser must be at
least 16 years of age,
payment can be completed as
part of that transaction.
Furthermore, including
reusable assets
such as an enterprise security
policy and a traffic management
policy will ensure adherence
to corporate requirements,
enabling faster time to market.
Because the lottery
API product packages
all of the necessary
items, applications
can be quickly created
to allow purchasing
of lottery tickets over a
wide variety of experience
that is convenient
for the player,
like online, mobile app,
and kiosk purchases.
Another example of the
API product mindset
is with one of our customers
who is the leader in ticket
sales and distribution.
The company uses APIs to enable
customers to discover events,
such as concerts
or sporting events,
and provides the ability to
purchase tickets on the spot.
This capability is
provided through APIs
made available to partners
who include the features
within their applications.
Perhaps you are planning
a weekend getaway
and want to reserve
a hotel room.
In the process of reserving
a room on the hotel website,
you might see a link to explore
events within the local area.
The link allows you to
discover events in the area
and enables you to buy tickets.
A one stop shop to complete
your weekend getaway agenda.
To enable this
experience, API products
make it easy for partners to
create the user experience.
Let's take a closer look at
this partner API product.
The company's
partner API product
addresses two key challenges.
How to enable both internal
developers and partner
developers, and how to
ensure the appropriate level
of security to stop bots
from circumventing limits
placed on ticket purchases.
Since security was a
must have, that policy
was automatically included
in the API product.
In addition, consumers
wanted to find events
using various search criteria.
Search by artists
such as Beyonce,
search by venue like
the AT&T stadium,
and search by dates
for the event.
The discovery API had all
of the necessary calls
to obtain the event data.
Finally, in order to reserve
and purchase the tickets,
you need a commerce API to
complete the transaction.
This could all be bundled in
a simple to use API product.
Over the course of
its use, the company
found that the needs of
the partner developer
were the same as the needs
of the internal developer.
So one API product
could meet the needs
of both types of API consumers.
Now that you have an
understanding of the API
product mindset, how do you go
about building an API product?
Let's dig into this.
Key factors in building
an API product are--
design your API product
with an outside end mindset.
This requires understanding
your customer and the use case.
In the case of the national
lottery focused on the player,
you might take on the
persona as a player
consumer I want to
purchase a lottery
ticket while I'm on the go.
For wealth management as
an individual investor,
I want to view my
account holdings.
Or as a financial
advisor, I want
to view my client's
account holdings.
Taking a look at
the consumer's view
informs how to design
your API product
from the most common use cases.
Next, take a look at the needs
of your application developers
who will create the
experience for your customers.
They need a way to get started
quickly with your API product.
That's why documentation
is so important,
but documentation
alone is not enough.
Make it easy for your
developers to discover your APIs
say through an Apigee
developer portal.
The documentation makes
the APIs accessible.
And finally, review
the analytics
to determine what works well
and what needs improvement,
then continue to iterate to
improve your API products.
Gone are the field of dreams.
There is so much
information bombarding you
through the world wide web,
email campaigns, social media,
and even robocalls to
disturb you that everyone
is on information overload.
In order to get the attention
that your API product deserves,
you have to market
and evangelize
your product directly
to your target audience.
Focus on your developer
needs, give them
what they want as far as ease of
use, onboarding, and adoption,
and make it fast
and easy to consume.
API product mindset means
understand the needs of others
in the digital value chain,
both upstream and downstream.
The application developer is the
consumer of your API product.
Documentation
describing the product
is the key to its success.
Likewise, for developers
to get started quickly
with an API product,
you must provide
foundational information to get
started, such as what data does
the API product provide,
how to access it,
and what is the
format of the data.
To recap, the API
product mindset
consists of three
key focus areas.
Focus on the user experience.
Think outside in, and
get a good understanding
of the user's needs in order to
create a positive experience.
Make it easy to consume with
documentation and sample code.
Time to market is key.
Every enterprise company
is jumping on board
to enable digital assets.
The first to market will have
a leg up on their competitors.
Iterate.
Don't try to boil the ocean,
but designed for extensibility.
Design for the basic
value proposition,
get feedback, and continue to
iterate to improve the product.
Thanks for your time, and be
sure to watch the next video
to learn about
customer journeys.